the third lesson  is to think deeply to be  quiet and think until  you know the situation you know the  right thing to say  and the right thing to say is the one  that internalizes considers and thinks  through the big picture  of the situation so the emotion you feel  especially when you're young about a  particular situation  the desire to be sort of a crybaby about  things about me me me  about being upset about this situation  or that situation  there was something about the way she  was  quiet and the way she looked over the  world  and the moments when she spoke  were words of wisdom of calm  and patience that was so inspiring  to a mind that was impatient she helped  me understand that the immediate  emotional response to particular  situations the ups and downs of how you  feel  influence the perception the cognition  of how everything is interpreted  and taking your time thinking  being quiet  and speaking when you have something to  say is the kind of man  i should be  you